today we are about to check out the new
iPad pro this was just announced to last
week and now we have one right here and
we're gonna check it out this is the one
terabyte edition the twelve point nine
inch Wi-Fi and cellular version this
does come in two different
configurations there's the Wi-Fi and
cellular version and there's two
different sizes there's the eleven inch
and the twelve point nine which we have
right here here we go
[Music]
it's the first thing that you're gonna
notice which is an upgrade from the
previous gen is the fact that it has two
cameras now so there's now a wide-angle
lens on this and a lot of people are
like why do I need a wide-angle lens on
my iPad you do I think I think everyone
does and now it's a possibility it is
here so I think if people do take a lot
of photos in their iPad this is gonna be
a huge upgrade because having that
wide-angle integration is awesome so I
think this is something that we're not
really very surprised by that is now on
the iPad the thing that was a surprise
was the fact that they have now added a
lidar scanner in to the iPad and this is
something that is used in NASA
technology it's used in surveying so
this really allows your iPad to get a
full sense of the area that you're in
and why this is important is augmented
reality I am such a huge fan of
augmented reality I think it's just such
a fun concept to be able to take the
world around you and make it cooler but
it's also such a mind trip the other day
when I was making a video just about
this iPad and I put the AR version of
the iPad on my desk still it's just so
wild because it really for a moment
tricked my brain into thinking that the
iPad was sitting on my desk and then I
realized it wasn't but now it is where
is it
so let's turn this thing on and I'm
gonna see what else is in the box the
stickers they gave us a nice little sim
card ejector and like always we've got
our fast charging brick pins USBC so
it's a girl with our iPad we have our
smart keyboard folio and one of the big
highlights now of his iPad is the fact
that it can use a trackpad support it's
a cursor but it's not really a cursor
because it's kind of a cursor that
mimics the touch on your iPad this is
actually a feature that's already been
used in the accessibility settings in
iOS so now they've actually made it a
full-fledged feature on the iPad so that
you'll be able to use a trackpad you
will be able to use also a Magic Mouse
one of the Magic Trackpad or you can
wait until May because they do have
another magic keyboard that is coming
out that has USB C pass-through charging
it also has an integrated trackpad and
it does have a magnetic little mount on
it so it's a case but you can also just
put your iPad on it and you can move it
130 degrees and fortune
we have to wait until May but for the
time being we do have this one this is
just their standard-issue smart Keyboard
folio it still has a keyboard and what's
great though is you can still use the
Magic Trackpad in the meantime I feel
like if you do have an iMac or something
like that one of these has probably come
with your computer yeah that feels nice
I'm gonna be writing so many tweets on
this thing man the iPad is just cool
okay we're gonna connect the trackpad
everything's all set up I'm pretty
excited to test this out just to see I
don't know why I'm so surprised it's
doing exactly what it's supposed to be
doing so I guess I can make my own
little computer that's not a computer
this feels exactly like I'm like I have
a MacBook in front of me I can touch it
so now I'm going to be trying to touch
my MacBook and what I don't have my
trackpad with my iPad I'm gonna be
trying to use a trackpad you can tell
like the little cursor is there to
simulate like you're touching the screen
now this is all set up I'm gonna go
through and download some apps and then
do an AR test I'm gonna do an editing
test take some photos with it and we'll
just see where else this review takes us
[Music]
I've been working on this iPad for the
past several days now and I've been
editing a vlog entirely shot on my
iPhone and edited on the new iPad pro in
luma fusion it's been really interesting
because I am a really fast editor when
it comes to editing in Final Cut when I
was editing in Lua fusion it's kind of a
whole nother process because I have to
kind of think differently about how I'm
editing everything is touched so being
able to touch my screen and use the
Apple pencil to edit so that was my
challenge to myself how do I do
absolutely everything on this iPad but
I'd like to say I think that the project
was successful I just uploaded the video
and I think people are going to be kind
of surprised to realize that I shot this
entire video on my iPhone and entirely
edited on the iPad even doing the
voiceovers so here I wanted to show you
guys my luma fusion workflow that I've
been doing so this five different ways
that have the interacting of using the
Apple pencil you can touch the screen
you can use keyboard shortcut keys and
you can use the trackpad and also the
Magic Mouse I haven't used the Magic
Mouse as much but as an example to see
that it does work like I'm opening up
luma fusion and you can use it just like
you normally would you can click on
things I love the Magic Mouse especially
for editing because you can just use the
touch on the top of it to scroll through
your timeline this has been something
that I do a lot with editing you could
also do that of course with the trackpad
two fingers swipe swipe through the
timeline and I can hit play and this
plays through and you can use the Apple
pencil to scroll I'm also ambidextrous I
mostly write with my left hand I use my
mouse with the right hand and when I'm
editing on a MacBook I use the trackpad
with my left hand and do most of my
shortcut keys with my right hand so this
has been a really confusing time for me
because I will sometimes switch the
Apple pencil over to my right hand and
I'm using that to scroll I am extremely
efficient in final cut so I'm kind of
trying to develop those same skills and
shortcut keys here with Lua fusion one
of the coolest things though is the fact
that I shot this whole video on my
iPhone but with iCloud I had all of the
videos all of the photos all of the
content automatically uploaded to the
cloud so it was all synced to my iPad
when I open it up so everything that I
was shooting it was already here I
didn't have to do anything else
something that was also really
interesting ism so he
- editing on a Macbook or an actual
sit-down desk so to be able to get like
super comfy and just edit like this it
was really strange and I kind of really
liked it I just want to give you guys a
look at the timeline of this video that
I edited if for my quarantined vlog if
you guys haven't seen it make sure you
go check it out I'll put a link in the
description and an annotation but this
is the whole timeline so you guys can
see up here that's all the edits that
I've made where the music is and this
was really challenging mostly because
using this program in this in-depth way
was very new to me so I had to kind of
learn all of this over again you can see
all over the multiple tracks we've got
some very precise edits here that are
happening to the beat of the music but
this is the whole timeline that looks
nice I also you been recorded the vo in
this video with the iPad this is a mic
that I actually got a vlog University
Apogee was there and they showed me a
demo of this and it's incredible so it
just has a USB cable that goes right
into your iPad and there's also an app
that connects with it as well but right
now I'm just using a luma fusion so it
has a vo setting you can just go to add
insert voiceover and a little dialog
pops up this is automatically detected
and when I hit record three two one
hello it's just gene talking about
social distancing stand six feet away
from your friend or no one so let's test
that out I'm going to click OK these
headphones plug its into the microphone
so that's monitoring the audio and
here's where we recorded our vo right
there and
that's it this is also great for
podcasting and maybe I can start a
pandemic podcast I don't know if that's
something that you guys would be into I
could be I just quarantine I guess let's
start it so here we go I'm gonna hit
record and this is gonna be coming to
you not live hey everyone it's iJustine
from i quarantine headquarters today
we're going to be talking about some
stuff that I've been doing and I've been
doing a lot of things I've been putting
eyebrows on my dog I've been learning to
edit on my iPad and now a word from our
sponsors I don't have any yet but we can
get some so one unplug this microphone
and then I'll let you guys hear these
speakers are pretty incredible and I was
also very surprised about the battery
life since I did spend almost a solid
day editing that vlog the battery life
was really impressive today we're going
to be talking about some stuff that I've
I'm using the lead vocals let's maybe
change this to let's see it some vocals
to a narrator I've been doing and I've
been doing a lot of things I have been
putting eyebrows on my dog should I
start a podcast on my iPad silent
whisper to chest now all it took was for
me to get a new iPad a new microphone
now it's time to test out some AR apps I
just kind of went through and searched
augmented reality I wanted to try some
of these new ones too I've never
actually tried before and the first
thing that I saw there was a crime
investigation last night the bloody body
of Trent park professional musician was
found lying in his Nashville apartment
so to evidence within the scene
access forensic tool that will help you
tie the evidence to one or more sons
Maddie I'm trying to solve a crime right
now they inspect I'm going to inspect
this a single some casings to identify
what type of gun was used we've analysed
this now let's check out the body let's
get some more s'more info
there's our suspects on the wall I don't
think I'm ready to accuse yet we have a
fingerprint
okay so that was pretty intense fun fact
my sister went to school for forensic
science I'm gonna have to show her this
app because I think this is something
that should probably be pretty good at
I like augmented reality for interior
decorating clearly this room needs some
help
it's I was originally going to set up as
a little studio space to shoot in and
right now I mean we've definitely shot
some things in here but with the IKEA
place act I'm gonna see if there's some
stuff here that we might be able add
I'll see what it looks like here so I
think I need some storage let's see what
this little storage space would look
like here well that's actually pretty
big so we're gonna need put that down
here oh yeah actually that could work
hey Jana what do you think of my new
shelf we gotta see it on here because
it's AR whoa wait a minute go back over
there walk in front of it my initial oh
my gosh walk walk across it just like
walk across the okay come back over here
now walk hot back away walk that way
what here hold it you can see me walk
past it I walked in front of it I'm
walking in front of the shelf Wow okay
so I I think I needed by the Shelf
whatever I want
[Music]
so this app is called Fraga pedia and it
has this AR anatomy of a frog so I can
pick parts of him I think this is his
eye what's that a lateral fold man I'm
gonna be so knowledgeable coming out of
quarantine
what are you been doing with your time
well I've been learning about the
anatomy of a frog and they are what
about you now we're looking at his
muscular system what what this is
something that I never thought that I
would be doing today and it is that's
okay
there's your stomach here's the
dissection a portion oh okay well all
right so we are virtually dissecting
this frog right now great job I'm doing
well a coil tube is a part of okay
here's your small intestine I don't
think I want to do that anymore well
that's a new way to educate yourself
about dissecting a frog without actually
having to dissect it I also love that
augmented reality is doing educational
things like this it's not just as it's
really for gaming or trying to decorate
your house so I think this is really
changing the way that people learn and
I'm here for it I think that I learned a
little too much I love all the creative
ways that a R is kind of able to bring
life into your home and I think now more
than ever I think this is something that
we need
I'm shooting front-facing video on the
iPad look how massive this looks it's
crazy
look at that look how big my face is so
crazy it looks like you have a big
iPhone it's well it mean essentially
this really is a big iPhone but the new
thing about this is the fact that it has
the new program was set up so it has the
wide-angle and the ultra wide so there's
Jena with the regular there's Jena
wide-angle look at that I can see your
feet they're not so good look could you
take a few photos for me hey put the
holes in it but make it fashion do I
look weird yes I feel weird
let's I'm gonna stand up okay I'm so
scared I'm gonna drop this well don't
quarantine fashion I put jeans on for
this and to make it fashion who's gonna
get a photo shoot he looks really bad
little Harry be there good you wanna do
you wanna be a good boy okay you do all
the things you don't really could do
time lapse in slow-mo you can shoot
videos photos portrait mode only works
on the front and you can do pianos boys
that's just a first look at the new iPad
pro I just wanted to show you kind of a
real-life scenario of how I would use
this there is so much more that you can
do on this especially with procreate
I've talked about procreate before I
have some free time on my hands as many
of us do so if there's anything else
that you guys would like to see here on
this channel
whether it's tech related or non tech
related let me know in the comments
below
I will see you guys later and I'm gonna
get back to testing out this iPad so I
can do a fun follow-up video for you see
you later
[Music]